[Music]
this year marks the tenth anniversary of
the Transformers franchise and the last
night is the fifth installment but
here's a fun fact for you did you know
that Entertainment Tonight is the only
show that has been on set for all five
of the blockbusters like I'm a kid again
one of those trains getting blown up
tonight
these are Michael Bay sets so things
blow up dangerous you know we shoot fast
and you know it's a big shot that's
Michael on the set of 2007 transformers
that one started it all I've never
experienced anything like this
it's where we first met child LaBeouf
fighting alien BOTS saving the world
Michael put a camera on the ground and
it's in a bulletproof box so you don't
break the camera and your face is right
next to it and you're thinking is there
protecting the camera why don't I have a
bulletproof box the location was New
Mexico's Holloman Air Force Base Josh
Duhamel even flew in a fighter jet
little bit excited two years later for
revenge of the fallen we were in White
Sands New Mexico Bay was like a dance
choreographer did me like one two we get
over the but this busy guy still had
time to Punk us a bit are you guys drunk
et/pt what's that did you get that on it
yo yeah we got everything on camera
including these incredible fly box
I think my favorite so far it has to be
real-life jets for 2011's Dark of the
Moon the action moved to Chicago where
famed Michigan Avenue was turned to
rubble we also saw base jumpers takeoff
from 110 stories up so come on into the
game let's go what are you doing look
for 2014 age of extinction we were in
Detroit and Mark Wahlberg had taken over
as lead car when you think about a
Michael basis that's the first thing
that comes to your mind autumn we're
gonna be working extremely fast downtown
Detroit is actually dressed to look like
Hong Kong and cars were being tossed
like toys but then production moved to
Hong Kong and we found mark in the exact
same outfit got the same blood from
Detroit yes it is I never washed it off
it's just really exciting the energy
here is pretty crazy
now michaelbay told me that he was
editing this last film up until the day
before the premiere in China of course
the global premiere is here in London on
Sunday and we will have everything that
happens on the carpet for you on Monday
[Music]
you